mes chers amis ce jour est un jour de
recommencement et ce congrès doit
traître le congrès du renouveau pas un
renouveau de façade pazar est pauline
âge un congrès du renouvellement des
idées parce que aujourd'hui soyez en
convaincus c'est nous et nous seuls qui
pouvons incarner le renouvellement des
idées parce que la gauche ne pense plus
avec un président de la république qui a
raté les trois premières années de son
quinquennat et qui va passer les deux
dernières années à faire campagne
un président de la république qui va et
vient de commémoration en célébration en
s'affichant en se mettant en scène
auprès de grands destins comme s'il
s'agissait de mesurer le sien d'ailleurs
si mode s asseyait grande personnalité
la gauche ne pense plus le ps pense pas
non plus est ce que les militants du
parti socialiste qui ont voté pour la
motion françois hollande valls et
cambadélis
on lui cette motion j'espère que non
c'est à se demander 38 pages creuse pas
une seule grande réforme pour la france
alors que le pays est à terre pas
seulement une seule idée pas l'ombre
d'une idée rien alors quand il n'y a
plus d'idées
ce qui reste ce sont les vieux réflexes
les vieux réflexes idéologiques on
déconstruit d'identité française
quand on ne peut pas reconstruire le
pays les vieux réflexes encore secteur
finkielkraut et beaucoup d'autres
intellectuels qui sont devenus des
pseudo-intellectuels notre président
nicolas sarkozy président de l'ump est
un dangereux selon cambadélis xénophobe
voilà la gauche donneuse de leçons de
nos leçons de morale alors mes chers
amis la gauche ne pense pas le front
national n'ont plus que marine le pen
aille à new york s'affichait au gala du
thaïs s'afficher aux côtés des
starlettes aux côtés des rappeurs
du show vis mondial ça ne changera rien
que marine le pen que marine le pen
découvre subitement tout d'un coup ce
que sont les convictions de son père ses
convictions que nous connaissons depuis
plus d'un demi siècle
ça ne changera rien non plus c'est un
ripolinage est derrière ce ravalement de
printemps il n'y a que de vieilles idées
de vieilles idées gauchistes parce que
marine le pen
je voudrais vous en convaincre c'est
jean luc mélenchon sans l'international
le ps tu penses plus et le front
national pense dans un monde qui
n'existe plus s'ils tentaient qu'il ait
jamais existé
alors les français nous demandent
justement de reprendre le flambeau du
projet le flambeau les convictions le
flambeau du renouvellement des idées
parce que le renouvellement des idées
c'est l'horizon indépassable de la
politique renan disait ce sont les idées
qui mène le monde les idées le
renouvellement des idées c'est le
meilleur ciment pour les républicains
quand il n'y a pas d'idée quand il n'y a
plus d'idées il n'y a plus que le choc
des ambitions charles péguy charles pays
qui est disparu il ya plus d'un siècle
avaient cette belle phrase tous ceux qui
élèvent unis et bien les idées justement
élèves
et puis surtout les idées sont la
condition de la reconquête la condition
des victoires de demain tout simplement
parce qu'il n'y a pas de grandes
victoires politiques qu'ils ne soient
précédés par la victoire d'idées le
général de gaulle l'avait bien dit il
l'a dit superbement admirablement dans
une très belle phrase en disant que au
fond des victoires d'alexandre on
retrouve toujours aristote et bien
demain les français au fond des rede
victoire des républicains
celle que nous allons demain encore une
fois remporté les français doivent
reconnaître nos convictions la victoire
justement des idéaux de la république
nos convictions qu'il faut'' bien sûr
assumer ça doit en être fini avec une
droite frileuses
celle qui trop souvent a eu l'habitude
de se coucher devant des injonctions de
la gauche
aujourd'hui nous nous nommons les
républicains alors n'ayons pas peur
aussi de nommer les choses
n'ayons pas peur de dire ce que nous
sommes ce en quoi nous croyons et nous
croyons en l'idéal républicain
la liberté bien sûr la liberté comme une
responsabilité personnelle la liberté
certainement pas comme le libertarisme
de gauche celui qui autorise l'industrie
de la gestation pour autrui la fabrique
des enfants ce qui autorise aussi la
marchandisation du corps des femmes la
liberté oui l'égalité aussi mais pas
l'égalitarisme légalité comme l'égalité
des chances mais certainement pas
l'égalitarisme certainement pas cet
égalitarisme qui condamne justement ans
lenny flanc en nivelant l'école et le
collège qui condamne les enflant à
s'enfermer dans leur origine à
s'enfermer dans la condition sociale de
leurs parents l'égalité la liberté et
puis bien sûr la fraternité le peuple de
france ne peut pas retrouver le
sentiment d'être un peuple sans ce beau
sentiment non pas d'un solidarité
seulement mais de la fraternité qui est
tellement plus exigeants régis debray a
eu cette phrase un jour oui la
fraternité c'est sans doute le plus beau
mot de la devise républicaine c'est sans
doute aussi le plus pauvre
là aussi la fraternité ça n'est pas
l'assistanat la fraternité ça n'est pas
non plus tant de choses qu'on décline à
longueur de médias la fraternité c'est
une exigence une exigence républicaine
alors soyez en convaincus autour de
notre président gérard larcher au sénat
rassemblés avec 944 sénateurs nous
sommes prêts au sénat pour ce
renouvellement du projet des idées
victor hugo avait l'habitude de dire que
la république affirme le droit mais elle
impose de devoir nous avons nous
républicain un double devoir le devoir
de faire respecter la république le
devoir de faire aimer la france nous
sommes républicains parce que nous
sommes patriotes et si nous sommes
patriote c'est parce que nous sommes
républicains
alors vive les républicains vive la
république et par dessus tout vive la
france
oh